- [Narrator] Here's a quick tutorial
on how to be miserable
for the rest of your life.
Step one, wake up whenever you want to.
Don't wake up at a reasonable hour,
an hour that makes you
feel good about yourself.
Make sure you wake up
when everyone has had a
head start to the day.
You really wanna make sure
you feel like you've missed any chance
to start your day off on the right foot.
And when you get out of bed,
don't make your bed and don't shower.
Just wear whatever you wore
yesterday and head downstairs.
It's important that you start the day off
with little to no self-respect,
feeling as grimy as possible.
Step two, make sure your house
is always a complete disaster.
Your house is filled with many rooms,
each with a specific purpose.
You wanna make sure that
it's extremely difficult
to accomplish those purposes.
The pigsty will also help
subconsciously reinforce the idea
that you're a disorganized person
whose life is not in order.
This is an extremely
important belief to have
when trying to remain miserable.
Step three, procrastinate.
When the thought dawns on you
to do something productive,
like clean your disgusting kitchen,
just ignore that feeling.
After all you just woke up,
and you have so much time later
in the day to get that done.
You wanna get in the habit
of delegating all your life's problems
to the future version of yourself,
who will probably have
a lot more motivation
and energy than you do right now.
Step four, look busy.
After you sit down to do some
work, open up a Word document
to help yourself feel like
you're being productive.
Give your document a nice title
and then immediately open up Reddit,
Instagram, Facebook, and Twitter
just to check if you missed anything.
You see, it doesn't
really matter what you do.
As long as you're sitting on your desk
and that Word document is open,
it'll help trick your conscience
into thinking you're doing work,
but you won't be getting
any further in life.
Step five, wait for opportunities.
Never be proactive with
finding new opportunities
to grow your career or meet new people.
Wait for all of that to
come knocking on your door.
After all, if it's gonna
happen, it's gonna happen.
You'll meet the girl
of your dreams one day
and things will kinda just work out.
You'll probably also land your dream job
if you just wait long enough.
Anyways, the important
thing is to not take action.
Don't try to figure out
the most effective way
to get what you want, just
wait until things work out.
Step six, be default no.
When a friend asks you to go
out for a drink, just say no.
After all, you're super busy these days
and have a lot of work to do.
When your boss gives you the opportunity
to lead a meeting at work,
try to find an excuse to slink out of it.
The key here is to give
everyone the impression
that they should just let
you do your own thing.
Be so good at saying no
that people just stop
asking you to do anything.
Step seven, be suspicious of people.
Never give people the
benefit of the doubt.
Believe that everyone
basically just wants to
take advantage of you,
and because of this, you should be guarded
and put up walls to protect
yourself emotionally.
Assume the smiles people give you are fake
and that their motives are malevolent.
Step eight, never fix the things
you dislike about yourself.
Continue to engage in activities
that make feel subhuman and weak.
Never prove to yourself
that you can overcome
obstacles or better yourself.
Never attempt to transcend your vices
or change your lifestyle for the better.
Subscribe to the idea
that people can't change,
so you shouldn't try.
Step nine, focus on
things you can't control.
As often as possible, get
pissed off at the traffic,
the government, the pandemic.
You really wanna reinforce the idea
that the world is messed up
and there's nothing you can do about it.
Focus on the shortcomings of others,
the failings of your country,
and the state of the economy.
Maintain a constant
external locus of control
over all the events in your life.
This will really help you feel powerless.
And if you're trying to be
miserable, that's perfect.
Step 10, use fear as motivation.
Make the fear of negative consequence
your primary motivator
for everything you do.
Set up deadlines that frighten you
and punish yourself for
failing to meet them.
Use white-knuckle tactics
to force yourself into productivity
and remind yourself constantly
that your entire life could fall apart
if you don't keep your head above water.
Step 11, only do what is comfortable.
Let your comfort zone be the authority
on what you do and don't do.
If it's not comfortable, don't do it.
Avoid discomfort at all costs
and participate only in activities
that are familiar and effortless.
Don't concern yourself with gaining
fresh perspectives or novel experiences.
Stay in your lane. Operate
in your wheelhouse.
Step 12, believe you're special.
Behave like you're entitled to things
on the basis that you're just
different than everyone else.
Assume that the people that
have what you want in life
just don't deserve it as much as you do.
Always regard yourself as talented,
unique, one of a kind.
This will really help you
develop an outsider complex,
which will make it difficult
to open up to other people
or see things from their perspective.
But since you don't wanna do
any of that uncomfortable
stuff anyways, that's perfect.
Step 13, see life not as it is,
but how you wish it to be.
Daydream of a day where things are better,
fantasize about a life where
all your problems are gone.
You wanna make sure you mentally
escape as much as possible
to distract you from the
obstacles in front of you.
Pour your mental energy
not into fixing your problems
or improving yourself,
but into building up this fantasy
to be as detailed as possible.
Reflect daily about what you would buy
if you won the lottery
or became a celebrity.
Constantly compare your
life to this fiction
and become resentful at the juxtaposition.
So if suffering is what you're after
and you crave the daily strife,
then you're in luck because
if you follow this advice,
you'll be miserable for
the rest of your life.
This video was sponsored by Audible.
The audio book I'm currently diving into
is "Greenlights" by Matthew McConaughey.
It's been on Amazon's bestseller list
for 23 straight weeks now,
and I wanted to see
what the hype was about.
And sure enough, I'm
really enjoying it so far.
I think the Audible version
is especially enjoyable
because it's narrated
by McConaughey himself,
which really helps his lessons
and tales resonate with the reader.
It really feels like
you're getting to know
Matthew McConaughey personally,
and he just seems like a cool guy to know.
For those of you who don't know,
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
and audio books
ranging from bestsellers
to celebrity memoirs,
motivation, productivity, and so much more
like original entertainment
and even podcasts.
Audible recently launched their
newest plan, Audible Plus,
and with Audible Plus you get access
to their entire Plus catalog,
which is filled with
thousands and thousands
of select originals,
audio books, and podcasts,
including ad-free
versions of popular shows
as well as exclusive series.
One of my favorite things about Audible
is that if you decide to
cancel your membership
for whatever reason at any point,
you still keep your entire
library of audio books,
including the audio books
that you got for free
using their credit system,
so it's kinda a no-brainer.
So to sign up for your free 30-day trial,
click the link in the description below,
visit audible.com/betterideas,
or text betterideas to 500-500.
Once again, to sign up for
your free 30-day trial,
click the link in the description below,
visit audible.com/betterideas,
or text betterideas to 500-500.
(gentle music)